- Boy, the Jets were tough. I don’t know how we did it but—
- Yo, if you enter someone’s selfie, does it become an us-ie?
- Delete video.
Hey, um, how are you backups doing?
- Just replacing a generational talent. You?
- We’re undefeated.
- Yeah, same.
- What?
- RED ALERT: THERE’S ANOTHER GOOD TEAM IN THE NFL.
- I THOUGHT WE HAD JIMMY “TAKEN CARE OF.”
- Hey, at the end of the day, we’re all still Tom Brady!
- [Together:] GET OUT, JULES.
- He has everything I have. A great defense.
- MAN, I SAW BAKER KICK A PUPPY.
- His own Gronk.
- COME ON! LET’S WRESTLE.
- I don’t get a Gronk till Week 14.
- PLEASE LET GRONK BE.
- Hey, man, you...you’re
You’ve met this old guy before. I wanna say it’s Joe Montana?
You’re an inspiration.
- Aw, thanks—
- But it’s all coaching, right?
- Well—
- He’s wrong. I don’t need Coach.
- You’ll always be pick 199.
- [Together:] ONE IS NOTHING WITHOUT THE OTHER.
- I AM MY OWN MAN!
- I’m a system quarterback, and that’s OK.
- YOU DON’T SEE MCVAY SHRINKING HIMSELF INTO GOFF’S BRAIN.
- IF WE’RE ALL MADE OF STARDUST, AREN’T WE ALL ALIENS?!
- AHHHH
- Ahhhh
- WEEEEEE
- They grow up so fast.
- HEY, YOU.
YEAH, ALL FREAKIN’ HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF YOU
Flipping listen to me.
I’m P.O.’d about the M.F.ing lurkers watching our B.S.
So subscribe to this G.D. channel or G.T. the Fluff O.
DADDY SAYS SUBSCRIBE.